The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK, so today
we're going to talk about some
of the probability models
associated with variation
in manufacturing processes.
The last couple
of classes, we've
tried to go and do two things.
One is give you a little
bit of perspective
on a couple of
different kinds of--
or actually, a
fairly wide family
of manufacturing
processes, give you
a little bit of exposure
to semiconductor processes
as well as a couple of
different mechanical--
mechanically-oriented
processes, and give you
some ideas or ways to think
about those processes,
including just the physical
action that's going on,
as well as some of the
sources of variation.
So we're going to
dive in a little bit
today on dealing with data
taken from some manufacturing
processes, and start to look
at random components of that
and systematic
components of that.
But back on the theme
of trying to make sure
that you have at least some
exposure, given everybody's
different backgrounds,
to these processes,
we would like to make sure
you have the opportunity
to at least see a couple
of the kinds of tools
and equipment in
the facilities--
especially those associated with
semiconductor manufacturing,
if you haven't
previously seen those.
So let me turn it
over to Hayden,
who can check in with
you well the problem
is that as well, but also
about arranging opportunities
for you to see a little bit
more, if you would like.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: So yes,
on the problem set, well,
if you still have
questions about it,
then feel free to
email or call today.
See me afterwards.
And problem set 2 is
now up on the website.
That's due on Tuesday,
the 26th of this month.
So there's a bit
longer for that,
and I'm willing to start
helping you with that too.
So thank you.
DUANE BONING: Any
questions for Hayden?
Any big issues with
the problem set?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I have a--
DUANE BONING: Go ahead.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a quick question.
So if you can refer to the
Question 3 of the Problem Set
1, and you say it's proportional
to the water and the time--
the KOH.
And when you talk about
these [INAUDIBLE],,
you're talking about
the concentration
or you're talking
about the molarity?
HAYDEN TAYLOR: What am I
saying is proportional to KOH.
DUANE BONING: The square
brackets around the KOH.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: The very last
figure [INAUDIBLE]..
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --proportional.
The [? edge 3 ?]
is proportional.
So it's proportional
to the concentration,
or it's proportional
to the molarity?
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Well, for a
fixed volume, it's the same.
There are two
lines on that plot,
and the models that are
put forward by [? Seidel ?]
to explain the data.
The data are the open
circles on that plot.
And there are two models
that have plotted.
And what I want you
to use are primarily
the experimental data.
So look at the curved line
that is plotted on that graph.
AUDIENCE: OK and for
the curved line that you
want us to look at, the x-axis
should be the concentration,
right?
HAYDEN TAYLOR: That's right.
Yes, the x-axis--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HAYDEN TAYLOR: --is
the weight of KOH.
In other words,
that's the number
of grams of KOH
per gram of water.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
just want to clarify.
That's it.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
HAYDEN TAYLOR: Anybody else?
OK.
DUANE BONING: I was
just also going to say,
it's sort of a
manufacturing process
that we use for making
up these problem sets.
And they are not expected to
be completely defect-free,
so we expect part
of the process is
detecting errors or questions.
And then we try to correct them.
Also, as a follow-up to that the
schedule for the next problem
set, just looking ahead for
the next couple of weeks,
the reason that the problem
set is due not next Thursday,
but rather, the
Tuesday after that--
a little bit longer
than a week--
is that here at MIT, next
Monday, this coming Monday
is President's Day, a holiday.
And then Tuesday is one
of these strange days.
You folks out in Singapore--
you may recall this.
Tuesday is a Monday.
So it's on a Monday
class schedule,
so we will not be meeting.
OK?
Go to whatever classes you
would normally have on Monday.
Go to those on Tuesday
out here to MIT.
And so then our next lecture
will be a week from today,
on Thursday.
OK, so also going
with the material
that we're starting
to talk about now
and the second problem set
that's just been released
is another reading assignment.
And in particular,
what we're trying
to do this year is focus--
do sort of the concentrated dive
of May and Spanos Chapter 4.
In the past, sometimes
we've assigned
instead Chapters 2
and 3 of Montgomery,
which are much longer.
Chapter 4 in Spanos
is a shorter overview
of basic statistical
distributions
and some very basic manipulation
and use of statistics
that we'll talk about today.
So we're not formally assigning
chapters 2 and 3 in Montgomery,
but the intent here--
what I mean by this
reading assignment is,
if you don't have very much
background on statistics,
you may want to read
Chapters 2 and 3.
Or you can skim
them to know what's
in there, and in particular,
that's probably the right place
to go for a longer explanation,
if you need more material.
If May and Spanos
is too condensed
for you or you'd like
additional examples,
there's a very nice
articulation in Montgomery.
Now, I have not made a formal
assignment of May and Spanos
Chapter 3, but that
is where you should
go if you want to
read more or need
to read more about semiconductor
fabrication process physics.
That chapter is a
very nice, again,
relatively condensed
description,
articulation of the key process
steps used in microfabrication.
We'll, throughout the
term, be popping in and out
of a few of those
unit processes,
and I just want you to be aware
that's what's in that chapter.
And you will quite likely want
to go in and skim that or read
that, and dive in
on some of those
processes if you
need more background
on some of those things.
And I think, especially
before this tour
that Hayden is organizing,
it'd be at least really good
to skim chapter 3.
Again, it's mostly on
the process physics,
but every now and
then, it does at least
show you a little bit about
the equipment that's used.
And it's very nice to be able--
for Hayden to be able to
point to some of the equipment
and components of that, and have
you visualize what's going on
in the process physics, or
be able to ask questions
about that.
OK, so what I'm going
to do here at the start
is just run through
some example processes.
And in particular, these
are little not quite
manufacturing processes.
They are more like research
scale implementations
of some basic manufacturing
processes that we have actually
generated some data from, or
students have generated data
from over the years.
So I'm going to show you
some actual measurements
from a few simple cases.
And we're going to
look at that data,
and what I think we're
going to see is variation.
And the puzzle for
you and for us--
and to some extent,
for me, because
in many of these
processes, I was not
involved in the
generation of the data--
our puzzle here is
to look at the data
and try to think about what
might be going on in the data.
So here's some-- a
basic turning process.
So we've got a work piece.
We've got under computerized
numerical controls, CNC.
We've got the ability to cut
into that work piece, which
is rotating, to try to get
to diameter work pieces
of a specified dimension.
So here's the diameter measured
on a particular location
on that work piece
as a function of 47--
I think it's 47 or 48--
different repetitions.
Now, I believe this
may have involved
more than one set of students,
or more than one class.
We can think of that
as a shift change
in a manufacturing process.
We're simply gathering here
a measurement of a diameter
on that work piece.
So talk to me.
Tell me what you see.
Is it uniform?
Not especially--
although you always
have to be really
careful looking,
because on any kind
of plot, you want
to really look at the spread.
Here it's kind of magnified,
because here's 0.7 inches,
and we're down to about
0.697 up to 0.702.
That's not full scale.
But if we zoom in around
whatever nominal is--
and in fact, it's not even clear
what the target dimension was--
I might guess and think
that it was 0.7 inches,
because that's a nice round
number, but who knows?
So it's definitely not uniform.
What else do you see?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The data is sort
of drifting up over time.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So it looks like there might
be a long-term trend of a drift
over the number of runs.
What might lead you to
think that that would
be a physically reasonable--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
So if the tool wears-- and
in fact, if the tool wears
or some long-term change in
the state of the equipment--
that's often the source
of these long-term trends.
Other things people see--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's
fairly systematic.
It constantly goes up and
down, and up and down.
There's only two or three
points before it goes back up.
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
that's very interesting.
Even the variation here--
it seems to be cyclical,
or periodic, or something
systematic going on in there.
Again, I wasn't there for
the generation of this data,
but what might some
reasons for that be?
AUDIENCE: The worker
might be trying
to correct with
the subsequent one,
and he overshoots constantly.
DUANE BONING: Interesting-- yes.
That's a good idea.
I guess, in fact, one
can imagine, especially
if you're taking a
measurement after every tool,
and the target was 0.7, say,
then maybe, near the beginning,
we're starting to
see a deviation.
Maybe this one was a
little low, and they're
trying to get back up, making
an overcorrection-- because
near the end here, it looks
like there's a little bit more
centered around 0.7.
AUDIENCE: I think
that might be because
of backlash [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So backlash
being an operator adjustment
that is made as perhaps part
of this compensation strategy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Interesting--
DUANE BONING: Anybody
in Singapore--
any other observations or ideas?
AUDIENCE: Since
measurement is measured
at a different
place of the things,
so maybe you can see
every three point
will be a larger diameter.
I think maybe this is
measured at the other side
of the thing [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe for the lower--
for the smaller diameter,
it's measured in the inner side.
DUANE BONING: Yes,
it's quite possible--
at least on this plot.
We might learn more if
we look at more data.
I read this as run number,
rather than measurement number.
So somehow, perhaps,
this is intended
to be representative
of the whole part,
but it's possible those
are multiple measurements
on different part--
portions of an overall turning.
You could start to look
and hypothesize on that.
Is the 1, 2, 3-- is that the
same pattern you see each time?
And it's not clear whether we
see exactly that same pattern
or not.
Other ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
So run number is a stand-in for
time, and these are occurring.
So your point here is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Sure.
DUANE BONING: Right.
So it may not be
equipment state,
or indirectly, it may be
also the rest of the facility
environment or the line.
And over time, who knows?
Maybe this thing
starts heating up,
or the work pieces
that are coming in
have a different temperature--
quite possible that there could
be some other long-term state
change.
We do notice there's
this shift change.
And referring back to
this long-term trend,
if we actually look
at this early part,
it may or may not be
drifting that much.
It may actually
be fairly steady.
And what we're
actually seeing in here
is an overall mean shift, but
maybe not even a long-term
trend.
So one might actually
pose, maybe even apply
some statistical
methods to look and say,
is there a statistically
significant mean difference
between this set and
this set of data?
So it may look like
a long-term trend,
or it may simply be a
reflection that there
is a setup change on
the equipment when
a new shift comes
in, or there may
be just inherent differences
in how the operator interacts
with the equipment.
How they load the part
might be slightly different.
Any other ideas?
Let's go back to the--
because I think
you had mentioned
something interesting about
possible oscillation in here.
What might other sources or
causes of oscillatory behavior,
or what looks like two
distinct sets of data here--
in fact, I'm not completely sure
that it's purely oscillatory,
because you can come
down here, and it
seems like sometimes
you've got two things that
are down low, and then one up,
or three things that are low,
and one up.
AUDIENCE: Well, this is
a little bit farfetched,
but maybe you could have
[? stock ?] material
of maybe 1 meter,
and they always
cut it into three pieces.
So they always have the first
piece of stock material,
and they had some
material properties that
led to have [INAUDIBLE] maybe.
And the middle piece led
to middle dimensions,
and the last piece led
to smaller dimensions.
DUANE BONING: I like that.
That might be very interesting.
So if I were generalizing
that, it may well be--
very often, there may
be more than one set
of starting material.
So it may have been all one
piece and cut into three,
and so they're randomly
picking one of the three,
and therefore, you're getting
a different mix of those three
points in here.
But in general, it may
well be in many cases
that you've got two
different incoming streams.
If I were looking at this,
instead of thinking of three,
it kind of almost looks to me
like this set of data here--
it's kind of randomly
around some value,
and this is a different set of
data around some other value.
So it may be that there's just
two boxes apart sitting there,
and they're just pulling,
randomly, starting material out
of one of the two.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I also
don't know if there's
any control on how far from
the [INAUDIBLE] the materials
[INAUDIBLE] you could put it
in, be a little bit farther,
and then it would have
a larger cantilever
arm than the next user.
DUANE BONING: Right, right.
So there could be
lots of sources
of both random and
deterministic variations.
So we talked in here about
things like a mean shift.
Maybe there's a deviation
between these two shift
changes.
And that would be a
either deterministic or--
systematic maybe is a
better word of a deviation.
And then, within
different sets, we
may have no detailed
explanation of why
we have these small
deviations, and a random model
for some of those components
might be appropriate.
So that's part of the
idea that we're after.
So over here on the side, we're
just referring back again to
of our variation equation.
Maybe I'll put that
up so that we can also
refer to that, because I
think we've touched on some
of these different components.
We said that our
deviations in our output
y you can often characterize
as some component that
has a sensitivity to
disturbances in our process
parameters, and
those disturbances,
and some component that
relates to our controllability
when we make small
changes [INAUDIBLE]
and then control inputs.
Among other things,
we said, well,
maybe some of our input
feedstock, maybe delta a's--
changes in the parameters.
We also-- and I thought it
was very interesting, talking
about overcompensation
in the control scenario.
It might be, in
fact, that there are
deviations or errors in
active control, changes
to the settings.
There may also be-- and we
also talked about it here--
is recognition that the function
y of our alpha may, in fact,
be time-dependent, or that--
put it another way--
some of the delta a's have
time components and time trends
to them.
We'll come back, and I'm sure
come up with more examples
as we look a little bit further.
And I think this is some
of the same process.
It has different run numbers
on it, but this is explicitly--
it looks like there's,
again, a dimension and run
number along the horizontal
axis, but in this case,
there's the yellow, our
inner; the purple, our middle;
and the blue, our
outer dimensions.
So you can imagine here
that perhaps measurements
are being made at different
locations on the work piece.
And I believe that
this line right here
is, again, a shift change.
So talk to me a
little bit about this.
What else do we
notice in this case?
There's one important
difference in this data compared
to this data that I'm
looking for in particular.
What additional
characteristics-- or what else
could you say about this data?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I guess
the spread on the [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: OK.
So one observation is,
if we were just looking--
well, right here,
this is a good one,
where inner, middle, and
outer are all close together.
But your point is,
generally, we're
seeing a very huge
spread in the measurement
within that particular
part than we do over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Much
tighter band--
so now you're talking
like a band here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Good, good--
yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING:
Interesting-- yeah,
so it's a situation
here where we don't know
the specifications, so it's a
little hard to actually know
which is better--
because your point you were
making is, in this case,
the blue's always above--
or almost always
above the purple,
always above the yellow.
And it may well
be that it's meant
to have a slight taper to it.
We'd need to more.
And actually, that's a
really important point
in manufacturing processes.
You can't just look at
the data and always know
what's going on.
You also have to have
information from design,
know what the
intended results are.
So certainly, just
to highlight a couple
of the things
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned,
one here is, very
often, we are also
interested in within
part variation.
So assuming that
maybe they all really
were supposed to have
the same dimension,
then this spread here is
very different than this
spread here.
So characterization of
within part variation
may be very important
in understanding that.
And then the other thing
here is, unlike this--
we still have all
that gook on here,
but in here we were basically
having a similar band,
and it was all just kind
of moving or shifting.
But the part-to-part variation
did not seem to change.
The variance of the process
The mean shifted.
So that's a very
common characteristic
that we're worried about.
And your point here
is that, in this case,
this looks like a much tighter
band, or the standard deviation
of the invariance of the
process in a run-to-run sense
is very different
than in this process.
And so it may be somebody with
a slightly steadier hands,
or a more consistent process,
or a more consistent operator,
or the equipment-- maybe
some change was made--
improvement to the
equipment saying,
hm, that little screw
is a little loose.
Let me tighten that down.
Who knows?
But something clearly
changed in order
to apparently
improve the process.
So those are a couple
more characteristics.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes-- question?
AUDIENCE: Professor--
DUANE BONING: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Since you
mentioned that maybe
with the shift change
there's some improvement
in the [INAUDIBLE]
of data, and that's
why it gives us a
smaller band right now.
But I noticed that the outer,
middle, and inner data--
they are pretty
close to each other,
as in the difference between
these three sets of data
are much wider in the previous
shift than in this right now.
So can we still say
that maybe this--
the object we are
measuring is tapered?
Because it doesn't look
like it's tapered right now.
DUANE BONING: Absolutely--
well, but the point
was made that we don't actually
know the design intent,
so this was a
hypothesis in here.
I think it's probably
unlikely that there
was an intended taper,
and I'll agree with you.
But in here, it
looks like there is
somewhat closer within
part correspondence
in these dimensions.
OK, so let me go to one more.
Here's another one.
This is brake bending
of a metal sheet.
The basic idea in
this process is
we're trying to change the
geometry under the application
of force in a bending process.
So we might have some tooling.
We have some piece of metal,
say, and we press down,
and the intent is to create
some permanent deformation
in the part.
An important component
here is that, when
we remove that force,
remove that pressure,
there can be spring
back in that part--
so little bit of the inherent
characteristics of this.
And so here's some data looking
at using the same tooling,
and I believe the same
set of downforce, with--
I believe this is a measurement
of the resulting angle.
Alpha is not a good
variable to use here, is it?
We call that just angle of
the resulting component.
And what else is changing here
is that the source material
is changing.
So in some cases, we're using
aluminum, some cases steel--
and also with
different thicknesses.
So I won't even
ask you to share--
the most obvious observation is,
depending on the material type,
we certainly get different
angles, different degrees
of spring back.
That's the most obvious thing.
What else do you see in this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It depends on the
thickness of the material.
DUANE BONING: OK.
AUDIENCE: So for the
same material [INAUDIBLE]
the springback, it will be more.
DUANE BONING: Right.
OK, and one could certainly
imagine good physical reasons
for that, that
thicker material is
going to perhaps spring
back more readily.
And one could even
go off and imagine
trying to build a first
principle physical model that
would tell you what
the resulting angle
or degree of spring back would
be as a function of that.
And in fact, it's
probably worth it
to go and consult
some literature
and see if there is
physical insight.
But if I were to ask you to
actually tell me what you think
the result might be if we
had a 0.45-inch steel part,
what would your
first inclination be?
Would it be to go to
the technical literature
and look up a physical
model for this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] averaging
between the [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
You would be basically
using some averaging
to deal with noise and
manufacturing variation,
but you would be building a very
simple empirical model based
on the data that you have, and
then interpolating in some way.
And here we've only
got two data points,
so you might pick the middle.
We don't know.
You might want to actually
go and design some experiment
where you add a
third point so you
know if there's some non-linear
dependence, and so on.
So that's certainly
an important thing.
There is a very
clear input-output,
a deterministic effect
that, again, you
would like to be able to
understand enough to be
able to deal with that.
And the same may also be true of
other discrete design choices--
discrete choice
being the material,
whether it's aluminum or steel.
You would like to know,
is it a similar trend?
One thing that's
very interesting
here is it appears
that the delta
as a function of
those thicknesses
is about the same--
very nearly the same
in the two material cases.
And then there's
a material delta.
So I'm already
starting to think, OK,
I can have a very simple
additive empirical model that
has a delta effect due
to the material type.
It's a binary choice--
or a binary coefficient,
depending on that.
And then an additional component
is a function of thickness,
and maybe that function of
the thickness is independent.
That delta from amine is
independent [INAUDIBLE]
material type.
OK, anything else going on?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
there is kind
of a drop in the
middle of the set.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes--
very interesting,
and maybe a hint almost of
something, but then it--
yeah.
So there might be something
systematic going on there.
The human eye is wonderful for
looking for patterns, isn't it?
Actually, one of
the challenges often
is using both engineering
judgment and when
the data is simple enough
to detect trends, but also
have statistical methods when
the volume of data is huge
or there are many things
changing at the same time
to detect possible
shifts and trends.
Anything else?
Yeah, you had more.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So you're worried
about this, and maybe this
also.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DUANE BONING: In
fact, we don't even
know if that's a still
component or an aluminum.
Yeah.
So in some sense here, if I
were looking at this data,
I almost start to think
these are relatively--
well, you'd have to ask as
a function in comparison
to specifications
to actually say
how well-controlled that is, but
there is relatively tight bands
with a couple of these shifts,
and then almost outlier points.
Now, would you think
that these points
are coming from the same
source of deviation that
might be at work in this band?
Might be-- but it's such
a large deviation that it
starts to feel unlikely.
And another use of
statistical methods
will actually be to
quantify, how likely is it
that we would observe
by chance alone
a deviation within the natural
variation band of such a point?
And the key reason is, if you
see something big like that,
there might be a
[? point cause. ?]
And it's quite possible in
here that the operator is
making a measurement on
each part and said, whoops--
something just happened here.
Something got
misadjusted on the tool.
I need to readjust it
and get it back in.
Maybe there's even a little bit
of something going on there.
Or it might have been
a single event that
wasn't-- didn't
require adjustment.
Maybe you go in,
you investigate,
and you go, that one piece
of source material coming in,
that piece of metal
coming in was much thicker
than it was intended to be.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah, maybe
that's a piece of aluminum right
in there, or this
was-- exactly--
this was a steel [? 0.3 ?]
in the aluminum set,
or steel [? 0.3 ?] in
the first one of those.
Absolutely-- that's
a cool observation.
Yeah, that point seems to fit
down in that distribution,
doesn't it?
Very interesting-- so
a couple of the points
here-- the kinds of things
we might be looking for here
are deterministic
and systematic kinds
of effects that we might
want to use modeling for.
And then we also
are starting to get
close to the statistical
process control thinking, which
is to say we would like
to be able to know what
the inherent or natural
variation of the process
is having to do with
these sorts of bands,
and then be able to detect
with high degree of confidence
that something
strange has happened,
and I better take action.
And that SPC, or
statistical process control.
Maybe we're going to see many of
the same characteristics here.
This is just a
little observation
from injection molding.
So this is a
plastic molded part.
We've got a wit, the part
along this dimension,
and down here we've got
a number of the run.
And also notice--
I'll just draw your
attention here--
there are clear
intentional bands here,
where this first segment
here says holding time
was five seconds,
injection press 40%.
And we're changing
here-- this is
a holding time of 10 seconds.
Here's another holding
[INAUDIBLE] of five seconds
and 60%--
and whatever is
lurking under there.
I think it's a holding
time of 10 seconds.
We could find out, but--
talk to me about this one.
Oh, I guess also
here, notice, we're
plotting two pieces of data.
We've got a width and
then some average.
So it's quite possible
that what we're doing here
is this is a point width
at a well-known location,
and than the average is
we take that measurement
on many, many locations
around the part.
Or it's possible we also
actually run multiple parts,
little mini batches of-- who
knows-- maybe five parts,
and I'm plotting the average
across that little batch--
that five-part batch, which
is another very common thing
to do in SPC. So tell me
a little bit about this.
What do you see?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So you're talking about
this band here to here.
Right.
In fact, this
might be the result
of a designed experiment,
where somebody
is trying to explore the
effective different process
conditions, these
four different cases.
And part of the
goal of that may be
to identify not only things that
are closer to a mean target,
but are also more robust--
inherently robust, meaning
they have a smaller delta a,
or are the process
itself has a smaller
sensitivity among at that
operating point to whatever
inherent disturbance, whether
it be temperature deviations
or what have you.
So that's a good observation.
It's also kind of amazing to
me here that the average looks
rock steady in these cases,
but these individual width
measurements have a
substantial deviation.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
average of all [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: We
don't really know.
I don't know.
Yes, it's quite possible
that this is just a plot.
So that's your point.
This may be [INAUDIBLE]
suspiciously so, right?
This may be the average
across that ensemble,
and all that is
doing it's not saying
it's an average of
multiple measurements
or multiple samples, but
that's just highlighting
that there's this delta.
And that's got to
be it, because--
exactly.
There's zero deviation
in those average points.
OK, but these are some of
the same kinds of themes.
We're, again, looking at offsets
from deterministic process
conditions.
We're looking at inherent
variation, ranges.
We may be doing
design experiments.
You could start to think
of empirical models that
would help to guide us to an
optimal point, the point being
there that maybe these
four conditions give you
a little bit of an exploration
across two different process
parameters.
One approach would be maybe
your target is 40.85 or 40.87.
You might pick the one
that was closest to it.
But if you actually
built a model, including
a model with
continuous parameters,
you could then interpolate and
drive even closer to a target.
Yeah-- another
question or comment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right,
one would guess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
So that's actually a
very interesting point.
When we start talking a
little about more about
design of experiments, about
the synergistic effects,
it may not be a
simple additive model.
You're saying, as we
go here, from 5 to 10,
we got an increase.
Here, when we went to 5
to 10, we got a decrease.
So the effect of holding
time may be completely
in the opposite direction
at two different pressures--
very good point.
So that means there is
some strong interaction
between those two-- or mutual
dependence between those two
parameters.
Man, we're getting very
abstract in this data.
We've got measurements on
the output and we've got--
some number of run
number on the side.
This is actually looking very
similar to some other things.
We see definite shift effects.
We see mean effects.
Again, we see
perhaps an outlier.
The point here was that-- and
this didn't come up earlier--
we keep looking and
trying to put blame back
on the manufacturing equipment
or the source material.
You also have to look carefully
at your measurement apparatus.
There's inherent
measurement error.
Even if the parts
were almost perfect,
very often, you're going to
have an inherent measurement
limitation and deviations
due to measurement error.
And you may have
loading problems
into the measurement apparatus.
So it's not always an indication
that there's part deviations.
In some sense, the
measurement equipment
is manufacturing process,
tool, or equipment
itself that is also
subject to deviations.
And in fact, part of
the applications of some
of the statistical methods
we'll talk about seek
to characterize or do gauge
studies of the accuracy
and capability of your
measurement equipment
and the components of
variation that affect that.
So for example, there's
a pure reproducibility
and there's a
repeatability component
to typical gauge studies.
One component,
just real quickly,
would be I've loaded the part
on the measurement apparatus,
and then I just fire whatever
the measurement sequence is
multiple times, and think of
that as a pure repeatability--
somehow the physical--
maybe there's--
it's an optical measurement.
There's scatter from extraneous
light sources nearby off
of that.
And then there might be
a separate component,
if I pulled that same part out,
took it out, and put it back
on, and did that
sequence of operations,
including the
operator operations.
Then you have a reproducibility
component that might be,
in fact, much larger.
So you'd need to understand, and
maybe decompose and break down
to those different components.
And then, if you
started to see that one
was a source of
deviation, then you
might look at strategies to
control or compensate for that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At one
of my internships,
the company was getting
a lot of [INAUDIBLE]..
They were really
trying to figure out
[INAUDIBLE],, and
when it went bad,
at the supplier [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING:
Absolutely, absolutely--
in some sense, it's often the
analogy of it's not working--
oh, check the plug on the wall.
Always check your measurement
equipment and apparatus
before you start diving and
tearing your hair out, going
too deep into debugging of
the manufacturing process.
Check each step along the way--
glad they discovered that
pin problem back in the--
at the case.
Oh, here's more.
What do we see here?
Again, some output as a function
of run number [INAUDIBLE]
again, maybe this
is another sheet
bending kind of component.
We see effects of shift
change multiple times here.
These are different shifts,
maybe different shifts
or different parts.
What's very interesting here
is that, under some conditions,
we have a nice stable,
not drifting in time--
fairly nice, stable,
or stationary mean,
with some deviation--
every now and then,
maybe something
that looks outside
of the distribution.
But in some cases, holy cow--
that's a very different effect
than what's going on in here.
And it's back to this is a very
clear drift that is definitely
not just a one-time shift.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When I looked at
the [INAUDIBLE],, and the first
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm wondering if
maybe the [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Perhaps--
or maybe this worker
finds a way that corrects for
it in a comparatively effective
fashion, whereas the strategy
used in this case over here
is not nearly as effective or
quick at trying to get back,
if that was the target.
And so in fact, one of the
challenges often in SPC
or other control algorithms--
or not even algorithms,
but control practices,
especially involving people--
is one shift or one set
of operators or engineers
in charge of a process
may learn things
that don't necessarily
get captured
and conveyed to other shifts.
OK, so what is going on in lots
of these examples is perhaps
the most important point here--
is that, very often, there
are two highly different
characteristics
that keep coming up.
There's systematic or
deterministic effects
having to do with the type
of the material, settings
on the equipment, choice
of process conditions.
And then there's also
random components.
There's the inherent spread.
And a key point here is inherent
spread you can almost never
completely get rid of.
I guess, philosophically, you
could ultimately maybe appeal
to quantum mechanics, that there
would always be some deviation.
I think very rarely--
perhaps in some
semiconductor processes,
we do approach truly
inherent physical randomness.
But generally, it's that
the understanding is limited
in what is contributing to
that small degree of spread,
or it's impossible to
completely control those--
that inherent randomness.
But then we also have
big disturbances.
They may still be random
events, but they are not
this little band, but they are
big events with a clear cause.
We may not always be able
to discern the cause,
or may not always be able to
discover it, but in many cases,
we've been
hypothesizing about many
of these big shift
changes or a big drift.
And a bit of investigation
and more knowledge
about the process
would readily show us
what's going on in those cases.
And in those, when
there's something
systematic or
deterministic going on,
the whole idea is you make
some changes to the equipment
to stamp those out.
And what we're often
going to be dealing with
is designing
experiments and whatnot
to try to understand systematic
components and eliminate them,
maybe as part of
the initial design
implementation of a process.
Or in an ongoing process,
when we see a deviation,
we've got to go and debug it,
find out what caused that,
and eliminate it.
And the natural
occurrence then is
that, over time, as you have
learning about your process
and manufacturing system,
you're generally squeezing out
these deterministic sources.
It's something-- was
repeatable, systematic,
and therefore, you can
come up with strategies
either to eliminate it
or to compensate for it.
Maybe you have to have
a control strategy that
recognizes that
source of variation
and keep squeezing it out.
And what you generally
are left with
are these random
components, hopefully
in a very nice, narrow band.
But we still need to
understand and model those,
and so that's actually where--
another place where the
statistical analysis tools are
really crucial, because then we
want to be able to understand,
what is the natural
or reducible--
irreducible component that we
don't know how to stamp out one
at a time--
and use that information
to be able to detect
in that small scatter when
something unusual happens.
And that's the idea of
statistical process control.
So what we want to do is
characterize the process--
particularly just
the random component,
assuming that we've
been able to squeeze out
many of those other
systematic components.
Why do we want to
characterize that process?
There's some of the things
that I've mentioned,
and that you've mentioned.
If I see one of
these points that
looks a little bit different
than the distribution,
we said that [? by i, ?] but
very often, the question is,
maybe there's a point that's
a little bit above some
of the other points.
Then you would often
want to ask the question,
do I really believe the
output changed, or is it
part of that natural variation?
And if we start to think
about some natural variation
and models for that,
including distributions--
which we'll get to
in just a moment--
then we can start
to ask that question
in a very systematic way, in
terms of actual probabilities.
Other reasons is
we may go back to,
did the input actually
cause the change?
Did I make some output change?
A very important point
here is, how confident
are we have these answers?
Very often here, we
were appealing to it
looks like that's a bigger
change, or this is--
it was a mean offset.
Well, that's OK to try to
convince your management
or convince your operators
that, look, something changed,
but in many cases,
you'd actually
like to be able to quantify how
confident you are that that was
either a deviation point or that
some specific decision that you
made had a true effect.
And so the probability
and statistical tools
are really, really
important for that.
So what are some ways
that we can actually
characterize and model
the random components?
Well, that's where we're
getting into random processes
and random variables.
And I hope you're
seeing this is the basis
for statistical process
control I've referred to.
And we'll dive into some of the
tools and techniques, as well.
Design of experiments--
so if we were
making that pressure
change or that time
change, how big of
an effect is it?
How certain are we within
the random natural variation
that the deviation-- or
the controlled decision I
made actually had a big effect?
And then finally, even with
compensation strategies--
like this-- one of the very
first things that we said--
in that oscillating case,
there might be inherent noise.
And it's quite
possible that somebody
could be making process
control feedback
changes to try to compensate.
But if they're trying to
compensate for something that
doesn't have, in fact, a
connection between the control
decision and the
true source of noise,
they may, in fact, be injecting
more noise in the process.
So understanding actually
how feedback control works
when we've got random, and not
just the systematic component,
is very important.
What are some ways of
describing randomness?
Actually,
philosophically, there's
a couple of very different
ways of thinking--
if you open up a statistic
book, in the first few pages,
we'll talk about this.
And from a manufacturing
perspective,
well, we're really
dealing with data.
In many ways, the
data tells us a lot.
And one approach here is to
look at actual large ensembles
or collections of data,
and look at histograms,
frequency distributions.
And we'll look at
some examples of that.
A very different approach is to
start with a pure probability
model that assumes
there is a universe of
and an infinite
number of samples,
and there are characteristics
of that infinite number
of samples.
And that gives us the tools
to put empirical observations,
like frequency histograms, on
a mathematical basis that we
can reason with.
So for example, a way of--
let me jump forward here-- this
is some thermoforming data.
Again, this is some
dimension, and then,
over this collection
of parts, we have a--
this bar chart, this
frequency histogram.
And what that's really saying
is, for each of the bends
in that histogram, I'm simply
plotting the frequency--
or relative frequency
that some output was
between the bounds of that bin.
And so what we are doing is
converting from historical data
into bins.
This is still discrete
bins, but then we're
associating that and
interpolating forward
to say, well, the probability
in most applications--
if I were to do
some more part, we
think that this
histogram, in some sense,
represents a larger
set of data, and I
can use it to talk about the
probabilities of occurrences
of new data in here.
So what do you see in here?
Whoops-- there's a little
insert here with the raw data.
Now, if I hid that from you--
it's hard for me--
I'm trying to put
my hand over this.
If I hid that from you here,
and I hid that from you here,
and you just looked at this
data, typical things you would
say about it--
it looks normal, or
Gaussian distributed.
Maybe you would think almost
it's completely random.
It's got to mean
and the deviation.
It's got a normal distribution.
Now look back at the data.
It's kind of drifting around.
Just a peek forward to other
things to be cautious about--
don't always believe or just
look at your statistics.
Always go back to the
raw data, because if this
were a characteristic
of my process,
I would say there is
a random component,
I think, here, but then
I'm also seeing maybe
some systematic drift that--
I'd like to go in
and squeeze that out.
And then, if I were able to
get that out of my process,
then I might have
a random component
that doesn't have that
deterministic or systematic
component.
And it might have
a distribution,
but it might be
much, much tighter.
So an important
point here is purely
empirical data doesn't always--
it may look random, but it
may have embedded in it--
if you were to deconvolve all
of the sources of variation,
this big random--
or this big normal distribution
may have mixed into it
lots of different
systematic components,
as well as underlying
natural variation.
Imagine, for example,
that I actually went in
and I got rid of
this long-term drift.
Would you believe that the
remaining variation is all
random?
I bet I could go and I could
plot it, and I bet it'd look--
the remaining deviations would
look mostly normal as well.
You think so?
Well, who knows?
You might go in and do some of
the other kinds of hypotheses
about systematic sources
that we were talking
about in the other cases.
For example, it looks like
there may be a bit of an up,
down-- there might be something
cyclical or periodic going on.
That might be another
systematic source.
It could masquerade as a
random normal distribution.
So there's always that mix in.
However, in many cases, maybe
you also want to live with--
it's not worth it to you,
or too expensive to go
in and eliminate, or
you tried and we're not
able to eliminate also some
of these wandering drifts.
And in that case, maybe
the best you can do
is at least characterize that
remaining variation, which
has a systematic component.
But you would still like to
have a probability model for it
so that you could detect
deviations that were outside
of that variation source.
So if I saw a big
shift up, I would
say I've got a
point way out here
in the tail of the distribution
that's highly unlikely.
And you'd still
want to use that.
So now, we might want more
compact ways of describing
this distribution.
Actually, in the
age of computers,
I think, with lots of big
disks and lots of great data
collection, one of the most
underutilized opportunities
is keeping around
all the raw data,
and actually using
empirical distribution.
So in some sense, it's kind
of a holdover from the days
when it was really tough
to keep track and use
vast amounts of data.
And we almost always
would start to say,
OK, I'd like a compact
way of describing this,
and I want to describe it
as something that only has
maybe a couple of parameters.
It has a mean and some
variance component.
But that's a different
philosophical point.
There's, actually, I
think, a huge amount
of statistical methods
that are underutilized
that deal with sampling or
resampling from raw data
that actually can capture subtle
things going on in the data.
We're, in this course, not
going to be using those things.
We're pretty much going to
seek compact descriptions
of randomness in ways
that we can reason about.
There are data-intensive
ways of doing
the same kinds of reasoning.
So one important point
here is we're often
going to take this discrete
binned kind of information--
we want to characterize it with
perhaps a continuous parameter
variable and a
compact distribution,
such as a normal or
Gaussian distribution.
And this is especially good
when the outputs are themselves
truly continuous
parameters, like a width,
a dimension of the part.
And one point here, just
to remind you-- especially
when we go to
continuous parameters,
you've got to be a
little bit careful
about talking about the
probability of your part
or your variable taking
on any specific value
in that continuous distribution.
Back here when we
had things binned,
I could talk about
the probability
of measuring
something in that bin,
within that range,
1.485 to 1.487.
But now, if I were to ask,
what is the likelihood
that I measure exactly
1.486, be careful.
That is a very, very
discrete value that--
when we talk about
continuous probabilities,
the probability of
getting any one value--
and it's truly continuous--
is 0.
You're never going
to see exactly that.
Now, with real
measurement tools,
we never have perfect
continuous measurements either.
There is always a precision
and a discreetness
capable from the tool.
So this is an
abstraction dealing
with the mathematical niceties.
I'd just point out
it's not exactly true
and measured reality and data.
So very often, when we
talk about probabilities,
we got to be careful.
The probability of
any one value is
0 what we talk about
really is the probability
of our measurement or whatever
being in some range that's
inherent in the distribution.
But we can also talk about,
for example, the probability
that the value be in
the range from minus
infinity up to
some value y star,
and that is a
reasonable question
to ask in terms
of probabilities.
And that is embedded
in this notion
of a cumulative probability
function, or cumulative density
function, or CDF.
Just to illustrate
that a little bit more,
we can do the same thing,
have a cumulative frequency
with discrete data.
So if I had that
underlying histogram here,
I could also build a
cumulative frequency histogram
that simply was giving
me the probability
that a part or measured
value was up to, but less
than some particular value.
And that's simply
the integration
across the PDF up to that
cumulative density function.
And we can do the
same thing that we
did with the discrete
probability frequency
relationship.
So we can approximate
the frequency with a PDF.
We can also look at the
cumulative frequency
and approximate that
with a cumulative density
function, or a CDF.
So we can have that
kind of an equivalent.
And those equivalents also,
again, help us interpolate
and ask probability
questions also
on values that may not have been
exactly lined up with our bins.
So very often, we're
going to be, I guess,
talking either about
the density function--
the PDF of some variable--
or the cumulative probability.
And there is this inherent
relationship between the two.
I describe the cumulative
probability as an integration
up.
The probability that some
value is less than or equal to
would be an integral
up to some x star.
And so that value right
there corresponds to that.
And then the inverse is--
relationship is true as well.
If I had a cumulative
density function,
I can differentiate that to get
down to the probability density
function.
So this is some basic
statistical concepts
that you probably
have seen before.
Many of you have seen it in
much more detail in 2.853.
OK, so very often,
the histogram does
suggest an underlying
approximate or convenient
probability density function.
Very often, we've talked
about normal distributions,
but a key thing to look at is
always look at your raw data,
because there may be other
perfectly reasonable continuous
or discrete probability
density or probability mass
functions that apply
in the discrete case,
such as a uniform distribution.
And so one of the
things that we'll see
is the family of some typically
emerging or typically observed
kinds of distribution models.
So very often,
what we're doing is
we're gathering data,
looking at these histograms,
and looking to see, is there
a consistent pattern, such
as we saw with the underlying
normal distribution?
And we're often then
trying to intuit
what that reasonable
underlying distribution may be.
There are ways-- and we may
touch on them a little bit--
to be able to test
whether or how
good a particular distribution
model may fit with that data.
And on the problem
set, in fact, you'll
explore things
like a qqnorm plot.
And I'm not going to
go into detail here,
but essentially, that--
assume a model-- for example,
what the probability density
function probabilities would be
associated with certain kinds
of observations, if it were
a normal distribution--
and then you plot
your data against that
and start to see how
well the data fits
that particular model.
Let's go back to
that original set
of data, the
[? c and c turning. ?]
If I were to plot that
as a distribution,
I might get something like this.
I might argue that my bins
may be too coarse here,
but what do you see?
This is a little tricky, right?
If I were to plot that
data as a distribution,
I might be tempted to say,
OK, that's one big Gaussian
distribution.
You could try that.
But again, if we look
back at the data,
another interpretation
here is, really--
you can start to see it--
it's bimodal.
It's a mix of two distributions.
So I guess the simple
point here is don't always
assume it's going to be just
a single distribution that's
underlying it.
There may be a mixture.
Similarly, here's another set.
And very often, again,
plotting your empirical data
in time order tells you
a lot more, but also
be sensitive to those
kinds of questions.
I could have started the
whole class off and never
shown you the raw data, and just
started plotting distributions.
And in some cases, things
might be more observable there.
Usually it's easier to see
perhaps lurking up here,
when there's such a
very clear time shift.
But here, this is the histogram
associated with these,
and it sure looks like one
normal distribution here
and another normal
distribution here.
Now, by the way, if
these things were ping
ponging back and forth, or
they were randomly picking
and it was one of those
source material deviations,
it might actually be
hard to detect that,
whereas the
bimodality-- the fact
that I've actually got what
looks like two mixtures-- may
actually appear more easily
in a histogram kind of form.
There's another example.
Here we start to see,
again, these two shifts,
and now you can start
to convert these perhaps
to two statistical
distributions, two
Gaussians with different means.
And now you can also
estimate parameters,
like what the mean shift is.
So once you've
got distributions,
now you've got
mathematical approaches
for being able to
estimate those parameters.
So this is just going back
to some of that other data.
OK, so some of the key points
here out of this portion
is, even if there's no
strong input effect,
there may still be disturbances.
And we'll often see a consistent
histogram pattern emerge.
And what we often
want to do is use
that either to detect
deterministic deviations
and squeeze them out, or once
we've done all those process
improvements and gotten
those all squeezed out,
we may still have an underlying
inherent distribution.
Maybe it's random
variation associated
with a Gaussian distribution.
And the key idea
is we can even use,
and importantly, we want to use
knowledge of that underlying
pattern.
It's not a systematic pattern.
It's a random pattern associated
with that distribution--
so that we can predict
behavior, and in particular, set
limits on normal behavior.
This is a nice case.
Maybe this is what we'll
consider normal behavior.
And again, I want to be
able to statistically
say, what's the
likelihood that some
of these points or a new point
belong to the natural variation
or not?
So we're going to typically use
analytic probability density
functions to do that.
I think we've already talked
about most of these things.
I've been emphasizing, by
the way, continuous values,
these width or
geometry parameters,
but there's also a set
of different statistical
distribution than the normal
distribution associated
especially with the occurrence--
random occurrence of point
defects.
And a little later
in the term, we'll
actually do some
yield modeling dealing
with things like
Poisson distributions
and in these sorts of
discrete distributions
that are more appropriate
to discrete events
or discrete occurrences.
We're going to be, in
the first part here,
dealing pretty much with
continuous parameters.
So this is just laying
out, again, a little bit.
We've talked about
some of these.
I want to build up
just very briefly,
get you going on some of
the basic definitions.
And then Chapter 4 in
Spanos really articulates
these much more.
So we have our probability
density function
and cumulative density function,
and there is that relationship
between the two.
And then we can ask
about certain moments
or characteristics of these
continuous probability density
functions.
These should be familiar to.
We can ask, what is the mean
or the expected value of one
of these distributions?
And here I'm using t as a
stand-in for time or run
number.
And if I have a probability
density function associated
with the random variable,
and even time, then
there we have a definition
of the expected value
of x as a function of time.
Now, I'm kind of being
pedantic here and giving
this definition, because
we also saw trends--
long-term trends in our data.
And we could ask what the
mean is as a function of time.
Again, we're in a
situation where I'm trying
to squeeze out those drifts.
So usually we're in a situation
where we want to avoid
non-stationary drifting
processes or analyses where
some of these functions--
the probability density
function and its parameters,
like the mean--
drift over time.
We typically want to be having
stationary processes where
the mean and other
moments, like variance, are
independent of time.
So in the stationary case,
which is what we're mostly
going to be dealing
with, now I've
removed the time dependence
on the underlying
statistical model.
Let's say, from time to
time, it should be stable.
And then we have a mean,
this mu of x-- the true,
or theoretical true mean--
that we would calculate
with the same formula.
But again, the idea of
the stationary process--
important characteristic there
is that the mean is a constant,
and not wandering or drifting.
Similarly, in the case when
it's a stationary process,
the variance, defined here
as the second moment--
the expectation of the
distance squared of your data
from the mean--
[INAUDIBLE]
expectation of that--
is the variance.
That's just the definition.
And in the stationary
case, that is also
a constant of the process--
has a nice alternative
little description,
if you work through
the mathematics,
where it can also be
calculated as the expectation
of the square of your data
minus the mean squared.
By the way, you can ask the same
questions-- variance, mean--
for any continuous distribution.
They're perfectly good moments.
In some cases, they completely
characterize the distribution.
In other cases, there may
need to be additional moments.
And an example here
is we could ask,
what is the mean of a uniform
distribution-- uniform, where
the probability density is
equal across an entire range?
And so one could
calculate those as well.
Everybody is seeing the
normal distribution.
Again, we can actually have
an explicit description
for what the PDF is.
We'll often be talking about
the unit standard normal or unit
normal distribution.
The full distribution here
actually has the mean in it,
and it has the variance in it.
So for your particular
process, those
may be very different for
whatever collection of data.
In order to be able to talk
generically about properties
of the normal distribution, and
to use tabulated values and so
on, this normalization, where
we subtract off the mean
to get a 0 mean
description, and then we
divide by the
standard deviation,
gives us the unit
normal distribution.
And that's exactly
always this distribution
in terms of z units.
Now we've made it independent
to the mean, independent
of the variance.
And the exact values,
the probability densities
for any values of z are
well-known and tabulated.
So we've made it 0 mean
and made it unit norm--
unit variance.
There is also a cumulative
distribution here.
I'm describing this
as p of z, so now we
can ask the cumulative
distribution
function for that unit
normal, and plot that.
For the normal
PDF, what's nice is
this is the whole
distribution, and all
we need are those two
parameters, mean and variance,
and it completely
characterizes the process.
And then there's some
statistical operations
that we can do for when we--
that are really convenient when
we have normal distributions.
For example, if we have
multiple effects, we can look,
and the sum of multiple
normal random variables
still has a normal distribution.
So I'm just giving you a
little bit of a peek here.
You can do some reading,
which is probably
more effective than me just
flashing by these things.
There are important
operations, for example,
where, if we have
an output y that
is a sum of multiple
random variables,
there are things like
the mean of the overall y
is simply the sum
of the mean of each
of these individual
random variables.
And if there's a scaling in
the mean, that simply scales.
There are also
operations when these--
if these are independent random
variables, the variances add.
And you've got to be
careful any constant.
If you run that through
the definition of variance,
those are also squared.
So you'll see the
basic description
of some of these
mathematical operations
and these distributions
in May and Spanos.
And you'll also
start to get a feel
for using these
distributions to ask
some very standard
questions, like what
is the probability
that you would
observe a value in some range?
So I think, with
that, we'll close.
If you want to get
started on problem set 2,
there's some problems that--
this is just basically
giving you some familiarity
with manipulating things
with Gaussian distributions
and other statistics.
And then we'll start building
up more detail next Thursday.